a quick announcement we told you in
november that we were doubling down on
fox news and fox news on us tonight
we're going to tell you what that means
starting in april we'll be launching a
regular podcast on fox nation it'll be
produced by the same people who make
this show
and backed by the same company that
keeps us on the air
whatever you may read about fox news on
the internet the truth is and we would
know
they are principal defenders of free
speech and they're
tough as hell we wouldn't be here if
they weren't
trust us every day there's intense
pressure to pull this show off the air
and
every day they resist that pressure and
we're grateful for that
we're also grateful for fox nation at a
time when the big tech companies have
decided to shut down
all inconvenient facts and opinions fox
nation is protected it's a subscription
service
big tech can't touch it it can't be
censored and that's a blessing
we won't only be starting a new podcast
though one of the first things we're
doing on fox nation is starting a long
form
investigative series called tucker
carlson originals it'll look much more
deeply into some of the things we talk
about nightly on this show
here's a trailer
i cannot believe i'm shooting on the
hickok 45 range
they're stealing what we have here in
maine they're totally forced
let's go be dogs my concern is
my safety my daughter we will pass that
they know that this corridor is more
than an
energy project it's an attack the weak
against the strong we're just so
delighted you're a gun
guy
that was the fun part we're working on a
lot of stories and have been
for months the series will cover a wide
range of topics and they will be
commercial free on fox nation i hope
you'll see them
two episodes by the way are already in
production they investigate the story
behind the green new deal
so when the power went out in texas on
monday we immediately sent our originals
team to find out what exactly was
happening
because we knew it would not be long
before the same ideologues who caused
this disaster
would be online claiming that the green
new deal their schemes
had nothing to do with it and we were
right they started lying within hours
but our team was there gathering
evidence on the ground
this footage was they took is from big
spring texas
as you can see the wind turbines aren't
generating any power
because they're not moving the
temperature by the way is not even that
cold it's 21 degrees but they are iced
over
no electricity our team in big spring
tells us the hotels nearby have no
water and of course rolling blackouts
are affecting the entire area and much
of the state of texas
now why aren't you seeing more footage
like this on other media
you know why journalists and the
politicians they exist to protect
are lying to you they need you to
believe that those windmills were a
great investment you paid for them
people already know that they're
expensive people who live near them know
they destroy the environment and
kill animals huge numbers of animals
but if people knew they'd crash the
power grid maybe they wouldn't put up
with it anymore
so they've decided to tell you that
these frozen wind turbines aren't really
a big deal not a big deal
quote no the green new deal did not
cause the texas power outage read a
piece today in new york magazine
right